so we'll wait couple more minutes and
then we'll start
good afternoon everyone
welcome to our session for the
introduction of the genome metagenomic
uh data analysis my name is farhana
mussara i'm a postdoctoral researcher at
lsu and also the program coordinator for
this course
so today we are going to give you an
overview a brief overview of the course
and then we will have two q a answer uh
session question and answer session
one will be on the march
fourth and the other one will be on
march 28th
so
in this um course overview
we are going to show you the course
materials and
if you have any other questions we and
try to answer those
so before we go to the course overview
let me remind you the registration
process one more time
so most of the people already who are
enrolled in this course they have
already registered but if there are
someone new and you are looking for the
registration process i'm going to go
through them over again
so if you are a part of lbrn program or
if you are someone working at lsu your
registration process would be a little
bit different than nappy or any other
who is not from lsu or louisiana lbrn
program
so if you are part of the lsu or lbrn
program you have to register through
the ilab
let me show you how you are going to do
the registration if you are part of lsu
or lbrn
so
first you have to create an account
in the ilab
once you have an account
you will be able to
log
in and then
these are the steps that shows you how
to register for the course
through ilab so once you register
you login in the ilab you will be able
to see the core facilities on the left
hand side corner you select the core
facilities
and then you select the seeder core
facilities and services
afterwards you have to request a service
and it should be here on the top right
corner
and then you will be able to select the
courses that you are interested in
so in this semester we are offering
three courses or three training modules
one is the introduction to
bioinformatics which we already started
the second one is the genomic or meta
genomic data analysis which we already
started and the metagenomic is starting
today
and the other one will be data science
for biomedical data intermediate and
that is other one we also started
already
so you can take all three courses or you
can take whatever you want and select
the courses here
write it down
and afterwards
this
tab will come this page will come you
don't have to write the fund number or
anything just write lsu or lbrn if you
are part of lsu and lbrn and then submit
the request to core
and this is how your registration will
be completed and afterwards we will take
care of it but if you are not part of
lsu or lprn you don't have to do
uh you don't have to do these or you
don't have to go through these
procedures i get a lot of questions uh
like uh people who are not part of lsu
they are filling out forms
uh filling out this form and trying to
register but
you just have to
email me that you are not part of the
lsu
but still want to register for this
course and i will direct you to the
other link
that
someone will help you to register
this course is absolutely free for lsu
lbrn or if you are part of the navy
program so you don't have to pay for the
courses
so now i will show you
after your registration in done is done
what you are supposed to do
so once your registration is complete
you can create an account in the omics
logic this is free you can create an
account there is no
charge for that
so once you create an account here in
the omics logic learnomicslogic.com
can click on your
email address here this is your profile
so if you click on the profile
you can give us some information about
you right for example you can upload
your picture
it doesn't have to be your own photo it
can be a your university logo or it can
be any other photos that you are
comfortable with
you can upload uh some information
here in the bio section like if you what
you are doing what you are interested in
your names and your social media
links if you are comfortable with it
so this will give us some information
about you
and then you will update this
information here
so in this uh
page you will see the courses programs
and everything in activity everything
here so if you click on the courses
you will be able to see the courses that
you are registered for
and
if you go to your profile and click the
courses here
you will be able to see
your activities and how much what are
the courses that you took and how much
you progressed like
percentage and everything
and also
if you click on the project
it will show you like how much you are
uh done or completed in the profile and
what are the courses you took and what
are the like how much points you got so
you can see here like earn 10 000 points
that means like if you earn 10 000
points you will be able to do your own
project using the pipelines provided by
us
so every time you finish or you complete
one course you will get or you would
earn some points and if you complete the
three
courses that we are offering this
semester it will be uh 10 000 points so
afterwards you will be able to run your
own
project so once you complete any project
um once you
complete any courses you will get a
certificate and
in the activity section here
it will show you like how much progress
you that you have done for example it's
uh i have not done a lot of activities
recently so it's kind of straight line
but if when you study and complete like
quizzes and stuff there will be a lot of
activity you can see a lot of peaks
okay um
i think i have covered um
like whatever i was supposed to
so this is the introduction course for
introduction session for the metagenomic
data analysis
and we will have two q a session in
march 4 and march 28th you will receive
an um an invite
also i will send you an in reminder
email
and you have to complete your
registration first and once you are done
you will be able to access the courses
by creating this an account in the
learnomics.omixlogic.com in this website
so now
elia will take over and go through the
course materials with you guys
thank you
thank you for hana and thank you
everyone who joined today
i will start by just adding to what for
hanan mentioned about registration for
those of you that are from nepea the
national association of idea principal
investigators
the link for your registration is right
here
all you need to do is you need to scroll
down and you will find the four
different programs that are
right here and click and then you'll
have a form that needs to be filled out
and somebody will get back to you
because we need to confirm
uh with nepy
about membership status and the number
of available licenses for free
so with that let me
start my presentation
so one of the things that we're trying
to do in these series of training
modules is develop asynchronous access
to the materials that have been
developed and piloted at lsu and lbarn
over the past couple of years
and make sure that they can be effective
at introducing these important topics
and provide a practical step-by-step
guide on how to get started with
analysis
so i'll briefly discuss the program
objectives how it is structured where
you can find the different resources
we'll also try to make sure that
everyone has access to those resources
if you don't we'll note it down so
if along the way
you see me posting some links
those links don't work for you you don't
see what i see on the screen please put
down your name
and your email address preferably in the
chat that way we can get back to you
so the program
is going to be structured in several
different
modules and so essentially what you will
see
are pr are live sessions that have been
recorded and translated into a
step-by-step tutorial
those are based on sessions that provide
an overview of the types of data the
types of analysis methods and then
practical applications how you can take
examples
and practice using those example data
sets on finding interesting
insights that maybe are the same or
different from what was already
published
and so to achieve that
we essentially
designed this process around each one of
the topics that is being offered so for
example this topic is metagenomics we
have three elements in the program the
logic or why are we studying the
microbiome
what is the data uh you know what are
the interesting questions research
questions that are being asked what are
the applications what do people do with
insights from this kind of data
then there's the practice step and the
practice step essentially provides us
with some
step-by-step
tutorials you know press on this kind of
a button and get this kind of an output
run this kind of code and get this kind
of visualization that kind of thing and
then finally project so we'll start by
looking at data types and different
questions that you can ask then we'll
talk about analytical approaches what
are they and why are we doing these
kinds of things
what are the different pipelines that
you have to run to process and prepare
the data for analysis or what are the
actual um you know pieces of code that
you can run to get some
some types of visualization that for
example are used in publications and
then finally we'll talk about projects
so how can you find data what does that
data look like what is the sequencing
data look like what is the metadata to
look like and how can we apply
everything that we have learned to these
examples
so typically the way we do this is that
we
do several of these interactive sessions
the sensations are intended to be
interactive that means that if you have
any questions
uh if you you know think that what i'm
saying doesn't make sense you can put
that in the chat we can stop and we can
address those things and make sure that
we can all move along
when we have the q a sessions which as
for hana mentioned we will have two q a
sessions
we want to make sure that we are helping
so if you have any technical questions
or conceptual questions or even if
you're thinking about a research project
of your own that you would like to
analyze then apply some of the methods
too
please let us know in advance we would
like to know prepare for that and be
able to share with you some of the
things that will actually help
and then finally we will introduce to
you to study materials so our
expectation is that
people come with different levels of
preparedness some people come with
minimal technical and maybe statistical
training so they are not able to start
independently at all
some people might be more advanced than
that so maybe you have done
bioinformatics for a different type of
data
maybe you have analyzed data in general
maybe it wasn't biological data or maybe
you're an experienced microbiologist so
maybe you've read such papers and you
kind of know what's expected to happen
you just don't know how to do it
independently so in that case we are
asking that you
kind of look at the material as not one
size fit all but find the appropriate
place for you
so the study materials are going to be
the same pool of materials but of course
you're welcome to choose and pick from
them and find something that fits your
purpose the best
and then finally we have these practical
assignments so the practical assignments
are going to be of two types
the first type is going to be practical
pipelines
that will start and we'll do this today
with demo pipeline so you don't even
have to analyze any data you just need
to understand the logic of each step
how do these steps connect into a series
of steps what we call a pipeline and
then what are the outputs going to look
like how many of them what types are
they
in many cases these are going to be
tables and to work with tables we
typically want to visualize maybe the
results maybe filter them and so all of
that will be provided as a an example of
a code
that kind of tries to illustrate the
main things that you should be thinking
about when you're analyzing such data
so again as i mentioned
some of this material is going to be
very basic and that's intended for those
that have
no background in metagenomics or
bioinformatics for that matter
and so
if you don't know the terminology you
know the things
that are not
maybe clear to you uh from the very
basic things
we have a course called in bytes and
molecules which is an introduction to
bioinformatics how do
how do we describe biological phenomena
with data and what types of analyses are
done to that data to make interpretation
possible
and the question that we have here in
the chat is can i get the recorded
session of this and yes after the
session is over we will email everyone
the recording of this session
so in this course bytes and molecules
you will find an introduction to
metagenomics so if you don't know what
metagenomics is at all this is a useful
place to get started and just to show
you where you can find this
so on the learn portal
after you have created an account
so i'm assuming that most of you already
have an account here
like for hana mention it's a free
account
so if you do have an account you go to
the courses tab
and right here in the search bar
you can search for metagenomics
or if you don't know
where to start bytes and molecules
so under bytes and molecules
right here introduction to metagenomics
the bulk of the material that we're
going to be reviewing in the course is
called metagenomics so course number
four metagenomics and so what i'll start
with today are some of the
few lessons in the beginning of this
course but my objective is to help you
get started so you can see what are the
types of activities that we're going to
be doing and you can think for yourself
where to get started with those
materials for your level
and
how far do you want to go so one of the
objectives as farhan already mentioned
is you can eventually apply some of
these methods to your own data or
develop a research project around a
publicly available data set i will talk
today about some of these data sets but
if you would like to go in that
direction you will need several things
and one of those things is going to be
a certain number of points which as for
hana mentioned you can get from
completing some of the coursework
another thing that you will need is
access to the tt bioinfo platform which
today we will make sure that you have
that access and if you don't by our next
session or maybe by the end of this week
we will make sure that you have that
access and number three you will need to
practice and learn how to analyze the
outputs or the tables and visualize them
and so today we'll take a look at some
examples uh very basic examples but just
to get started how to load in such data
how to visualize it and how to interpret
it
okay so here as i mentioned there's an
introduction there are some overview of
different types of sequencing data
overview of methods of analysis and then
some coding exercises that we're going
to review today together
so
the the course inside will provide you
with a fairly detailed overview of each
one of these steps but today we're going
to kind of skip over the details just to
get the different pieces in place
and to get you started so this session
is not intended to be
a full detailed review with practical
outcomes this is supposed to be an
orientation and then you can proceed
with whatever kind of picture interest
or maybe
if you want a more structured view you
will see a schedule on the program page
so to get started with uh metagenomics i
think what we need to uh start with is
we need to understand that uh you know
the idea behind bioinformatics in many
ways is going to be getting started with
something practical that takes in some
data provides us with a series of steps
and provides us with an output and that
output is something that we know how to
interpret
one of the examples that we'll look at
today is an example of a pipeline called
the data 2 pipeline so this pipeline
takes in sequencing data
then looks at what are those sequences
in terms of a reference database and how
much of each one of those types of
bacteria we have and then visualizes
provides us with a visual output that we
can think about we can try to interpret
as we go into all of these different
methods you need to see that there are
many different alternatives to those
methods and what we'll see today is a
package that we will
briefly take a look at called filostiq
in r that will be useful for different
types of visualization techniques that
are standard for this one type of
metagenomic sequencing data that we will
review today
so let's talk about microorganisms and
the microbial community
the connection between disease and
microorganisms has been established in
the 1800s and already towards the end of
the 19th century laboratory methods for
growing microorganisms in the lab
culture were developed helping
characterize them with staining
these studies provided important
information about bacterial function in
isolation however it was soon apparent
that most microorganisms live in complex
communities today we know that the
microorganisms or the microbiota that
make up the human microbiome are not
just unicellular organisms living
alongside each other but instead form
highly regulated structurally and
functionally organized communities
attached to surfaces as biofilms with
interspecies collaborations as well as
antagonisms that contribute to ecologic
stability
the human microbiota is estimated to be
10 to the 13 to
10 to the 14 of microbial cells
recent estimates have been making that
about one to one microbial cells to
human cells ratio even though at some
point it was reported that there's a
much greater number of microorganisms
some of these figures were um updated
and so
the the numbers are actually derived
from the total bacterial cells in the
colon uh the organ that harbors the
densest number of microbes however each
one of these microorganisms
carries important functional properties
in genes that contain genomic
information these properties and the
genomic information by about
microorganisms have been of a growing
interest to the scientific community
resulting in over 100 000 publications
the majority of these studies have
focused on the intestinal microbiome but
as you will see many different
applications of metagenomics have been
are available for us to interrogate
so here we can see a recent publication
this is a review
actually i'm going to share this link as
well
so if you would like to
[Music]
get started this is a a great review
recently
published
where you can see how
different types of
areas on our body contain different
numbers of
microorganisms and what are some of
their properties
but also there's a table here
that shows the number of pubmed articles
on different types of diseases that are
associated with the microbiome so the
search was disease and microbiome and
you can see here many different types of
disease that microbiome has been
extensively studied
for
one example is
the skin microbiome so the skin
microbiota
has the ability to form these highly
stable communities
these communities
are hidden
in kind of areas that are difficult to
reach and so they're not easily removed
and changed and so you can see here some
examples
of we will see some examples of how we
can study the composition of skin
microbiome that will allow us to
determine differences between different
regions of the skin or different
conditions of the skin for example
acne
and and healthy skin now a lot of this
information or a lot of such studies are
based on our ability to have a baseline
so once we know what the baseline is
what is the healthy condition for
example or the normal control
then we can start understanding the
impact of different types of conditions
for example specific types of
microorganisms that are highly prevalent
or maybe
how the whole microbiome changes in
diversity and asks questions about the
specifics and so the ability to
establish these healthy
baselines
is being addressed by
a large collections of microbial data uh
that are
organized in these projects large-scale
projects for example
the human microbiome project or the
british cut project the american gut
project
there's the earth microbiome project
right so all of these different types of
projects that seek to collect enough
data for us to be able to study and
compare to these baselines some of the
specific types of experimental data
that could be generated
so to be able to analyze such data we
need to have
these four different things number one
we need to know what does the microbiome
represent and one of the important
things about the microbiome is that it
doesn't characterize a single organisms
it characterizes a community of
microorganisms that have some kind of a
relationship to each other
the second thing that we need to
understand
is
how can we
generate digital data
that represents
this community
and so here we need to speak a little
bit about different types of metagenomic
sequencing
including amplicon sequencing
whole metagenomic sequencing
metatranscriptomic and others so how can
we actually study the genomic material
in a given sample from a microbiota a
community of microbes and understand
what is happening or how many different
microorganisms do we
see
once we have that sequencing data we
need to understand what can we do with
such data so how do we actually go from
having raw sequences of individual
genomic elements
to some kind of an interpretable
image or
maybe a statistical comparison
that we know what to say about so here
we'll talk about
diversity uh presence and abundance and
maybe
different types of functionality
that essentially some of this
some of these microorganisms can be
associated with
and that is essentially one of the
objectives of this kind of analysis is
to be able to interpret what is going on
and so that heavily relies on our
ability to annotate
uh the different elements that we can
find and here the limiting factor is
that there are many more microorganisms
than and a lot of variation within these
microorganisms than what it has been
annotated and and obviously this
annotation continues
as an effort into
characterization of the different
microorganisms
okay so again if there are any questions
along the way uh feel free to add them
in the chat and those will be very
useful for us to continue this
discussion
so
for managed genomic sequencing
um okay so thank you repeata where can i
find the lecture and q a session
schedule for the beginner course
so i'm not sure what the beginner course
is
for this metagenomic
course we have a page that has all of
that information if you're speaking
about the introduction to bioinformatics
maybe you can put your email in the chat
and i'll send you that as well
okay so today we will take a look at one
of these examples uh one of the uh types
of sequencing that is uh commonly used
for metagenomic sequencing analysis or
for metagenomic sequencing is the
sequencing of the 16s
ribosomal rna gene
so the 16s what's called amplicon
sequencing is a technique that is widely
used to study microbiome directly in its
environment and it focuses on the 16s
ribosomal rna that can be amplified with
pcr amplification the 16s gene sequences
contain
hypervariable regions that provide
species specific signature sequences
useful for bacterial identification
so the bacterial 16s gene contains nine
hypervariable regions v1 to v9
ranging from about 30 to 100 base pairs
long that are involved in the secondary
structure of the small ribosomal subunit
the degree of conservation varies widely
between hypervariable regions with more
conserved regions correlating to higher
level taxonomy and less conserved
regions to lower levels such as genus
and species
while the entire 16s sequence allows for
comparison of all hypervariable regions
at approximately 1500 base pairs long it
can be prohibitively expensive for
studies seeking to identify or
characterize diverse bacterial
communities
these studies commonly utilize the
aluminum platform
which produces reads at rates of fold
and 12 000 fold less expensive
than the 454 pirate sequencing in sanger
sequencing respectively while cheaper
and allowing for deeper community
coverage illumina sequencing only
produces reads that are 75 to 250 base
pairs long up to 300 base pairs with
aluminum ic and has no established
protocol for reliably assembling the
full gene and community samples
full hypervariable regions can be
assembled from a single illumina run
making them ideal targets for the
platform so here you can see
that the 16s
ribosomal rna
about 1500 base pairs long and then we
have these v1 to v9 conserved regions
and so choosing some of them one or a
couple makes it um
you know a good candidate for these
kinds of
studies
now to analyze such data once such data
is prepared we can reference the
different databases that contain
sequences of the 16s ribosomal gene like
you can see right here
green genes the 16s ribosomal rna gene
database and tools or the silva a
comprehensive online resource for
quality checked and aligned ribosomal
rna sequencing data so essentially what
we can do is once we can generate
sequences of those 16s ribosomal rna
genes or the hypervariable regions of
those genes we can search these database
and find the best matches to then
provide annotation of what have we
actually found
so the 16 as taxonomic classification
is based on the ability to
sequence
a particular targeted region
which is amplified so we actually lose
the actual
specific abundance of that particular
gene that is present in the sample
and we can
now look at composition so the
proportionate abundance
and so once we look at that annotation
we can use the different levels of
taxonomic classification to then assign
proportions and when we talk about
baseline studies we can look at
individual regions on the body and we
can for example establish some
composition that is stable across
several individuals
so the um
this is just one of those sequencing
techniques um in fact uh there are
several different other approaches
for example
you can look at
rna-based approaches meta
transcriptomics
or
there's an ability to sequence all of
the uh you know not just the 16s but try
to sequence especially using long read
sequences uh sequencers that have become
more accessible and and cheaper in the
recent times uh we can actually uh
sequence either the full 16 ns ribosomal
rna gene which could provide us with
ability to better characterize um the
you know lower level of taxonomy so it's
more detailed
or in some cases even be able to
assemble
the actual full genome which could be
extremely interesting because uh we can
only rely so much on knowing one
individual gene only and assuming that
everything else stays the same
now another
uh kind of ability to study this kind of
data is to try and see not only which
genomes are present but also which genes
are being transcribed and so with
metatrans we're relying on rna
here it's important to separate the
genes that are being produced by the
host as opposed to
the
actual
microorganisms that are present and then
there's also mass spec mass spectrometry
where we can see
analysis of the proteins and the
metabolites that are being produced
[Music]
okay and raphael is asking
whether 30x coverage is enough so again
uh many different applications
uh but you know if you have a specific
question enough for what you know we can
probably uh talk about that as well
so ultimately though when we have this
idea of uh you know what is present
and maybe in what proportions
um ultimately i think the whole field is
trying to move in this direction of not
only what does that mean that we have
more of this microorganism or less of
that microorganism but what does it
actually
mean functionally right
how can we
use this understanding of composition or
what genes are being expressed to
ultimately say okay what does this mean
what is that functional
component of this type of information
and for that i think the whole field is
moving into greater detail
and that means combining more and more
different types of data to be able to
ask these much more specific questions
and apply them to uh things like
described here you know the impact on
the immune system or maybe interaction
with drug metabolism
and other
questions like that
okay so let's
do a little overview of where we can
find such data
and what does this data
look like or what can it be used for
so again not a long time because we will
spend a little bit more time on some of
the practical things so you can try and
get get started but we'll do a brief
overview so one of the things that you
will find very useful i think and
intuitive is this american gut micro uh
american gut project
the american project is a citizen
science project dedicated to metagenomic
sequencing of world citizens that are
contributing their microbiome samples to
the study of healthy or almost healthy
microbiome variability so the idea is
can we ask people to collect their
microbiome samples
skin and gut samples send them sequence
them and then we are starting to collect
this
natural variability and one of the
examples that you will find in the
american gut microbiome project which we
will actually try and do in this program
is uh look at an individual single
sample right so let's say i contribute
my sample how can i look at my sample
for example you can see right here my
sample is this first bar
compared to the average
similar diet so people that are on a
similar diet like myself
same gender similar bmi age
and some individual michael poland in
this case so some individual that we can
compare and as you can see the
comparison consists of different colors
here
that are annotated right here
and for uh you know kind of
understanding my individual sample now
we can start looking at the most
abundant microbes
at different levels of taxonomy
so these different levels of taxonomy
now can give us some reference that we
can try and see
what is known about these individual
microorganisms or taxa of microorganisms
down below you'll see how different
sites
so
hmp here stands for human microbiome
project so that's where we get the
reference kind of how does this compare
to the population
so how can we compare to some of these
other sources of information
from different body sites
different ages and populations and the
american gut population so
this is a project that i think is
fascinating uh provides us an insight
into what could be done just kind of to
understand what's going on but also
together with this information you can
find metadata so
that was sequencing data
what are the microorganisms that are
present this is an example of metadata
so this is metadata from the human
microbiome project the human microbiome
project contains a lot of different
variables that are being collected from
individuals
and in this one example we are using a
comparison between people that exercise
rarely and exercised regularly
so here you can see
we can control for certain conditions
for example they don't have
the liver disease
they are considered to be a healthy
subset of people
they rarely or maybe regularly
supplement with vitamin d
but the biggest difference here is that
the exercise is
never versus daily right so one of the
questions that you could ask from such
data is if we control for as much as we
know uh for the different factors could
we find
some individuals that are different in
one particular way
and then based on that difference you
know see whether there is or is not a
difference in their microbiome so just
an exploratory simple question and we'll
take a look today at some of the ways
that you can start thinking about these
questions
using this kind of data
another example that we will look at is
how the skin microbiome varies
uh between acne
and what's called uh perioral dermatitis
uh so a very common condition that a lot
of people have either experienced uh or
may might continue to experience uh you
know
the perioral dermatitis is more of a a
rash and acne is a more acute condition
and then of course we also have areas of
healthy skin so one of the questions
could be
you know how do these microbes
essentially interact with the skin
itself
in inflammatory acne right so how do
they cause inflammation
and so here in this discussion we can
also download the data and we'll look
today at where this data could be found
and try to understand what are some of
the differences so in this case
the difference is represented in this
image right here which is a
non-metric dimensionality scaling
plot that allows us to see different
samples positioned in this
two-dimensional space
and maybe show us specific grouping
based on this annotation kind of giving
us a sense overall whether these samples
are different or not and and here we
have three different samples
adult acne none which is healthy control
and perioral dermatitis
another more complicated study in terms
of how it was performed and exactly what
was done to develop the data to kind of
prepare the data is a study
that was published
in 2015 um that spoke about obese gut
microbiota induced neurobehavioral
changes in the absence of obesity right
so in this case uh the researchers were
trying to separate
the obesity
itself for example resulting in
some genetic predisposition or maybe in
some kind of a diet
from the impact of the actual microbiome
or the you know
the composition of microbiota so could
we actually take
the microbiota of mice that were fed a
high-fat diet
use that microbiota to
implant a specific composition into a
healthy mouse
and then see whether that led to some
new behavioral changes
and
if you read this publication you will
find that yes they found an association
with anxiety and these kinds of patterns
of behavior
but what we can try and do is we can try
and take this data and try to understand
differences between several different
types of data that are available with
this publication now of course these
kinds of publications uh illustrate some
of the approaches they can become
more and more complex in nature and you
will find that there is a great interest
in trying to
understand the functionality the
functional applications and even develop
treatment for example here you can see
a treatment for alzheimer's disease that
targets the microbiome
so different types of applications of
microbiome obviously going beyond some
of the basic research questions and
trying to incorporate the micro the
microbial signatures into into practical
applications including clinical
applications like treatment or even
understanding of
the impact on other types of treatments
like for example
immunotherapy
today living in the pandemic
of course we all might have questions
about well what is the relationship
between the microbiome and covet 19
and here's an example of a study
where
the
microbial diversity is being studied uh
for
long coveted and for susceptibility so
here you will find high-risk groups
coming to covet 19
and
as a result of the pandemic providing us
with such uh tremendous quantity of data
some researchers decided to collect that
data as well
and uh found some differences between
the length to recovery
and the speed of recovery as well
the microbiome is also
used not only in medicine but also
biotechnology and agriculture for
example microbial fertilizers mf's
constitute an emerging class of organic
fertilizers and consist of dried
microbial biomass for instance produced
on effluents from the food and beverage
industry they have been shown to provide
unique benefits especially in harsh
conditions at the same time with minimal
environmental impacts metagenomic
studies on agricultural applications of
microbiome are showing promise and many
have already started using this approach
to improve yield and resilience of crops
and so the types of applications of
metagenomic sequencing and sequence
analysis really uh continue and uh go on
and on and what we'll see is we will see
how
these types of metagenomic studies
focused on the microbiome as a whole
are very different from the way
microorganisms can be studied in
isolation but just to compare and
contrast here are some examples of
microorganism studies in isolation not
as a community where you can see
drug resistance viral adaptation or
association with a particular
phenotype that could be studied once you
have the full genome of the
microorganism
okay so now let's talk a little bit
about some of the practical things that
we can do
to analyze such data and again this is
not going to be a very detailed overview
but it should provide you with a high
level understanding of some of the
practical activities that you should be
able to do
after completing this training and uh
you know how you can continue thinking
about some of the research questions
that we cover up until now
and
try them on different types of data sets
so the first thing that we're going to
do is we're going to try
and
learn this data to pipeline just by
understanding the sequence of steps how
do we go from raw data to process data
and then what are some of the outputs
what are some of the visualizations that
we can get at the end so to do that
let's go to the server which is
server.tbio.info
this is a platform
that has a lot of the methods
implemented in a user-friendly
environment
and
in addition to that you will get some
demo
examples where you don't even need to
run any analysis you just need to
understand and visualize some of the
data
so please log into this
platform
if you don't have a login for example
you just joined today you haven't really
registered yet
you won't be able to do this together
with us now but if you have created an
account on learn within 24 hours you
should be receiving your account details
so just to get a sense of how many of
you already have an account could you
put number one or yes or something in
the chat so i know
okay great so two people
so if you do not have an account
uh but you would like to have one for
continuing
please email support at time
dot bio
okay
okay so unfortunately those of you that
don't have an uh access you won't be
able to do this practically but you will
see that these are very simple examples
so once you get the access it will be
easy for you to replicate
so what we'll do here and we've changed
some things around you will notice that
some things have changed not so long ago
we have moved the metagenomics section
right here and what we will do today is
we will just take a look at this last
example called
amplicon16s18s so if you click on this
drop down
you will
open this
section right here
and this is called
the data 2 pipeline so you will find
right here in the middle a section
called data2
now we're not going to go into a lot of
detail about this what i want you to see
today is just how to run a demo pipeline
what are the inputs and outputs and what
does it mean where do you go from there
so here you want to click on start
you can see what we cover today kind of
what is being sequenced the data 2
pipeline is specifically designed for
pair and metagenomic sequencing data for
amplicon 16s ribosomal rna
so here the 16s ribosomal rna
hypervariable regions are being
sequenced not the full gene
and then one of the objectives of this
pipeline is to actually denoise the
actual sequences so the more precise the
sequences that we have the better we
will be able to match them accurately to
the reference database and then if we
have an accurate match we can then also
analyze differences in composition or
maybe
how they are related to each other
phylogenetically
so here an important step
is to understand the challenge right and
and one of the challenges is with this
great diversity of microorganisms that
we are studying that we are sequencing
there is expected to be a lot of
variation and because of that variation
it's important for us to differentiate
between
technical variation like noise and data
coming as a result of inaccurate
sequencing
maybe because we don't have a lot of
good coverage or maybe because
um you know there is a lot of diversity
how do we actually understand the
biological diversity that we have we
have to denoise and uh kind of eliminate
the mistakes and to do that
we need to uh merge the parent reads
and then combine them into what's called
operational taxonomic units that allows
us to eliminate a lot of the variability
that is inconsistent unfortunately it
also reduces a lot of the reads
that we will have but we are only going
to be keeping um reads that are accurate
um and and could be matched to something
so once we do this i'm going to quickly
go through some of these
some of these steps we want to assign
those to the right reference in this
database
and assigning them
means that now i cannot just speak about
individual otus operational taxonomic
units but i can group them
by whatever level of taxonomy i was able
to annotate them by
and uh you know one of the challenges is
going to be the lower we want to go on
the taxonomy scale
the less information we might be able to
get
because of these hyper variable regions
and their variation but also because of
the coverage and how precise we know
which one came from there now from this
point on
we essentially have several different
tables those tables include a table of
otu
abundance or how
much of a particular operational
taxonomic unit i have proportionately in
each sample
and the annotation of where does that
otu mapped to from the reference
database
because i have the reference database i
also know the relationship between them
how close are they to each other could
they be grouped in some way how far away
are they evolutionary from each other
and then i can download i can do perform
downstream analysis which includes
building that phylogenetic relationship
with ape and then visualizing the
results with philosophy which is a
package in r
that allows us to make visualizations
and all kinds of statistical analysis
that then we can interpret in terms of
differences between groups of samples or
looking at individual samples
so once we do that and we click on end
right here
we will look at some of the output files
so once you click on ok
right here you will have a folder called
download pipeline output files
okay how many of you
were able to get to
this last
screen that i have
okay perfect
raphael did anyone else
okay if you did not
uh again i'll just repeat the steps
really quickly so from areas of analysis
down here
amplicon16s18s you click on this drop
down
go into the demo
start
qc filtering
replication accounts
pair merge
cluster consensus otu
remove chimera
assign taxonomy
ape
and then follows to you
so after this you click on end
and you get the download pipeline output
file just open this up and now you have
several different things and these are
the kinds of results that you're going
to be getting from a pipeline these
results will include
tables txt files for example
plots like these pdaf plots right here
faster files of actual sequences and
those are the major types of data that
you will have to deal with
okay so as an example right
this is going to be explained in much
greater detail
in the course
so when you go into the metagenomics
course
and you want to understand what was it
that we were doing
right here you have
a practical 16s metagenomic analysis
lesson that you can review
understand each one of the steps
and see all of the results in one place
but before you jump in there
you want to go through all of these
different sections to understand what
kinds of sequencing data do we have
what are the specific ways to analyze
them and then even practice some of the
basics so that you understand what is
going to be in an individual sample file
and to do that let us take a look at
another example so let's go
uh now hopefully everybody has a good
sense of what we can do on the platform
just what kinds of things we're going to
be doing
and here we're going to be doing
something else here we're going to try
and run a piece of code in r and at the
end of this session you can download
this code and run it on your system as
well
so what i will do is i will go into this
lesson six
okay this is the link
and we'll just go through this lesson
with a little exercise at the end
okay so please let me know once you're
on this link we're going to take just a
few minutes it's not going to be a long
time
uh
all right perfect
so here we have a different problem
there we had multiple samples and the
question was
how do these groups of samples compare
to each other
in this case we will just take one
sample so we don't have anything to
compare to we just want to understand
what's in it
and to do that we will use a different
pipeline so this is a pipeline that is
going to do something very different
here we will take full 16s ribosomal rna
gene that is a sequence
we're going to align it to a reference
database of all 16s ribosomal rna genes
we're going to count how many do we have
of what kind
and we're going to annotate them
okay and so here
the basic table that we're going to be
dealing with looks like this
you have individual elements genomic
elements
for example 16s ribosomal rna
and you can see how the kingdom phyla
etc is organized according to the
different taxonomic classification
with
how many of each kind do i have
and then you will also be able to
annotate
right so separate them
and see
how many do you have of different types
of for example phyla
right so if we just focus on phylum
we can see how many of each kind do we
have now they will come up many times
right because multiple organisms fall
under different phyla so we need to
combine them together
so after we combine them together we can
calculate percentages
what's the percentage of a particular
type from the total that we have
and obviously we can visualize such data
right we can prepare some kind of a
visual representation
and that is sometimes more informative
we can do a pie chart
or we can do a bar plot so essentially
we can see
what is happening with our data and so
this lesson is to be able to do these
simple steps in r
if you already know r
you know that for many different
applications in r there's typically a
library that already contains many of
the functions that you would like to use
so you don't actually have to reinvent
the wheel
some of these packages are very specific
like filoseek they just produced a set
number of plots that are useful for a
particular application like for example
phylogenetic analysis for philosophy
but some of them are more general
libraries and those libraries include
ways to visualize data and create
different plots or maybe calculate
different statistics for different types
of things that you can find
so here we'll do something very simple
we'll
learn how to load our data prepare a pie
chart and then we'll make a bar plot
because bar plot could actually be
more easy to interpret visually than a
pie chart
so
the objective would be just to
understand
how many of each kind do i have in a
particular single sample without
having to compare to anything so here we
have some code
and let's just go through this code
really quickly
we load in library
this library is to load an excel file
now sometimes you will have csv files
txt files
excel files so you need to be able to
load those data and load them into your
environment into your script here we'll
do it right here on our server but
you can also do it in r
so
then we want to sort
the data
and sorting the data is useful because
instead of looking at
images that look like this
we can kind of organize them to all look
like this from highest to lowest
and once we do that we then
create percentages
make a pie chart and also make a bar
plot at the end
so let's see how difficult is it for us
to perform all of these steps including
adding some color here as well
okay so here you have a
a console which is where you run the
code
and in this console you already have all
of the data and all of the script loaded
in
in fact if you want to use this data set
on your computer you might want to
download it right here so just right
click on this link
and download linked file
if you want to see what happens when you
run this code this code should run in
exactly the same way on your computer as
it does here the only thing that you
need to remember is that we're using a
library
yes you can run it on our studio
but in our studio you will need to have
the only library that we're using is
this additional library excel
to read excel files
okay so let's try to run it
and you can see that first of all we
have a success right we we correctly
have the answer
and right here we have the results so
this is
a pie chart that we created and this is
a bar plot that we created and this bar
plot is already annotated
now let's try
how to change just one little thing so
that we know that this is actual code
that runs and not just
you know an automatic uh button
so one of the things that you can see
here
is that when we create a pie chart or a
bar plot
we actually call give them a title main
is a title
and here we also make
different dimensions for our plots so
we're going to do two things we're going
to increase the dimensions because this
is kind of small
and we're actually going to change the
title
okay
so here we're going to
change this to pie chart
and here we're going to add bar plot
and you can try to do this in our studio
as well
okay
so here you can see that we also
add
uh
the label to our x-axis
and so when we look at the x-axis right
here in the bar plot you can see
bacteria type
okay but actually the type
is
by a phylum right so
here we want to add
okay
now
once we do this oh yeah we also wanted
to increase
um
the size
so let's do like this
and let's run it again
okay so here
pie chart right we change that
and here we also changed phylum and bar
plot right here and i noticed by the way
that i capitalized the c so we can make
it smaller
so this is an actual piece of code if i
want to take it to my computer what do i
need to do copy right here's the copy
code button
open our studio
if anyone doesn't have our studio we
have a little tutorial on how to install
our studio
and then you can run the exact same code
obviously you would need to set up your
environment to have the library
and to have the file okay so here's our
studio
let's make it bigger
create a new script
paste it here
okay and and here right we have this
library i already have it installed
let's run it
okay object labels is not found so right
here we have
so i think
what is happening let's run it like this
okay
like this
and run it like this
all right and so there we have it it
also works
in our studio
okay so to summarize because we're
already going over time
let's
wrap this up and summarize what we have
done today
the objective of this program
is to provide us with
methods of analysis that we know how to
perform and we know how to interpret
today we ran a demo pipeline called the
data 2 pipeline and we saw this data 2
pipeline in terms of the inputs and the
outputs
kind of understanding the logic of
analysis
now there are many other types of
analysis that we can do and we looked at
this annotation
of 16s ribosome rna
we have the kind two pipeliners as well
and we have this data two pipeline so we
can look at those different examples and
how they approach the same problem with
different other methods
we also looked at this simple example of
visualization how can we visualize the
data that we have from sequencing
and
we saw that we have this abundance of uh
proteobacteria in this particular sample
now what do you do
moving forward
so i recommend
several different publications
that you can
go through uh to kind of get started uh
moving further into
this field of metagenomics
there's a good review of the human
microbiome project which contains a lot
of 16s ribosomal rna data used in a
variety of studies
you will also find here in a paper i'll
share the links in just a moment
bioinformatics for micro my
research concept strategies and advances
and also explore the actual human
microbiome projects as well so these are
this is a collection of data
that has uh 16s as well as metagenomics
as well
and you can see different types of
collections within this
project so let me get you
these links real quick
okay so here are those links
okay now moving forward inside the
actual
tutorials
you will find these different additional
resources
an overview of sequencing methods of
analysis
different project examples including
some exercises that you can do and then
hopefully after you complete that kind
of training you will be able to apply
this to a data set of your own so we do
have a whole project where you can
go through several lessons on how to
develop an independent research project
including where to find data how to plan
for your analysis and if you need help
how to submit it to some of our mentors
to give you advice
and direction on how to develop an
independent research project with omix
data and bioinformatics
that's all for today
excellent raphael i'm glad to see that
you were able to run this in r as well
i will be available for questions during
the q a session
yes you will learn how to do alpha
diversity and beta diversity as well we
have that in the lessons
um and you will see it in violence as
well so please go through the lessons
again this was not a lot of information
uh just for us to get started but
as you come up with any questions or
challenges technically or otherwise
please email us as you can if you are at
lsu
please reach out to farhana uh if you uh
are not from lsu please please reach out
to support at pine bio or you can reach
me directly also helia at pine bio as
well
all right excellent thank you rafael uh
glad that you were able to join and uh
this recording will be shared with all
of you as well
so we will email to everyone who has
registered for the course and we hope to
see you again for the q a session
thank you everyone take care
thank you